To fight those massive fires out west... there are these camps, hidden from view. If you were driving by, you might not even know they're there. One of the largest fires in California history, the Creek fire, has a base camp for 700 people in the parking lot of a ski resort in Central California, just outside Fresno.
为了扑灭西部那些巨大的火灾……有这样一些营地，隐藏在人们的视线之外。如果你开车经过，甚至可能都不知道它们在那里。加州历史上最大的火灾之一——溪火（Creek fire），在加州中部弗雷斯诺市外的一个滑雪场停车场，设立了一个容纳700人的大本营。
Hose that!
把水管铺好！
Pull!
拉！
So if you know where to go, the first thing that you see when you pull up to camp is these 20 somethings running back and forth with bright yellow firehose, hundreds and hundreds of miles of it. Their job is to untangle miles of hoses all day, every day.
所以，如果你知道要去哪里，当你到达营地时，首先看到的就是这些20多岁的年轻人，拿着亮黄色的消防水管跑来跑去，那里有成百上千英里的水管。他们的工作就是每天，没日没夜地解开这些缠绕在一起的水管。
One of our producers, Miki Meek, recorded the sound that you're hearing right now and talked to these guys, including RJ Brown, who's 23, in a dirt streaked yellow jacket and a face mask with a panda nose and mouth printed on it. The official motto of his employer, the California Conservation Corps, which sends young people all over the state to do this kind of job?
我们的制片人之一米基·米克（Miki Meek）录下了你们现在听到的声音，并采访了这些人，包括23岁的RJ·布朗（RJ Brown）。他穿着一件沾满泥土的黄色夹克，戴着一个印有熊猫鼻子和嘴巴的口罩。他所在的雇主机构——加州保育队（California Conservation Corps）的官方座右铭是什么？他们派遣年轻人到全州各地从事这种工作。
Hard work, low pay, miserable conditions, and more.
艰苦的工作、微薄的报酬、悲惨的条件，等等。
You guys, what?
伙计们，什么？
"Hard work, low pay, miserable conditions, and more"-- that is the actual motto.
“艰苦的工作、微薄的报酬、悲惨的条件，等等”——这就是他们的真实座右铭。
What's the best part of your job, and what is the worst part of your job?
你工作中最好和最差的部分是什么？
The best part? Oh, I should know. Hang on. I'm going to start with the worst part. Just the worst part is when they say over here on the walkie talkie, oh, we got 60,000 layers of hoses coming in. And then, once the 60 comes in, they bring in another 30.
最好？哦，我应该知道。等等。我先说最差的部分。最差的部分就是当对讲机里传来：“噢，我们有6万层水管要送过来。”然后，当这6万层送来后，他们又带来了另外3万层。
So when you hear 60,000 hoses coming over the radio, what is going through your head when you hear that?
那么当你从收音机里听到6万层水管要送过来时，你脑子里在想什么？
Defeat. Like, I want to go home. I'm like, oh, no, no, no. I don't want to do this.
挫败感。就像，我想回家。我就想，噢，不，不，不。我不想做这个了。
The way this job works is this. Trucks come back from the fire line and dump huge piles of jumbled hoses. Five guys untangle them. And then, with each hose, they take one end--
这份工作是这样进行的：卡车从火线上回来，卸下一堆堆乱七八糟的水管。五个人把它们解开。然后，拿着每根水管的一端——
All right, ready? Everybody grab a corner.
好了，准备好了吗？大家抓住一个角。
--and sprint across the parking lot. Each hose is 100 feet long, so it's kind of a long way to go. They lay down one bright yellow hose next to another next to another, until the whole parking lot is blanketed with tidy yellow hose.
——然后冲过停车场。每根水管有100英尺长，所以路程有点长。他们把一根亮黄色的水管挨着另一根铺好，直到整个停车场都铺满了整齐的黄色水管。
What do you do to keep yourself sane when you're rolling hoses?
你在卷水管时做些什么来保持理智？
I'll just be thinking about music in my head that I have already listened to. And it just keeps me going.
我会在脑子里回想我听过的音乐。这能让我坚持下去。
They're not allowed to wear headphones on this job. His teammate, Kory Rovy, has a different strategy to deal with that.
他们在这项工作中不允许戴耳机。他的队友科里·罗维（Kory Rovy）有另一种应对策略。
I sing it out, and I tell everybody.
我把它唱出来，告诉每个人。
What song's on your mind lately?
最近脑子里在想什么歌？
"Can't Break My Stride." It goes like, last night I had the strangest dream. I sailed away to China in a little rowboat to find ya. Ain't nobody going to break my stride. And so, that song just keeps going in my head.
《Can't Break My Stride》。歌词是这样的：昨晚我做了一个最奇怪的梦。我划着小船漂洋过海去中国找你。没有人能阻挡我的脚步。所以，那首歌就在我脑子里不停地转。
Why that song?
为什么是那首歌？
Next step in this process, they wind the hoses up in coils, put them on pallets, wrap them in plastic wrap, and send them to be cleaned. After that, the hoses go out to the fire line again, then back to the hose rolling crews, then back to the place where they're cleaned over and over, week after week after week, which is life at a fire camp. They have the same day over and over and over, until the fire's out.
这个过程的下一步是把水管卷成线圈，放在托盘上，用塑料包装好，然后送去清洗。之后，水管再次被送往火线，然后回到卷管队，再送回清洗的地方，周而复始，周复一周，这就是消防营地的生活。他们每天都在重复同样的事情，直到大火熄灭。
When Miki visited, the Creek fire had been going for nearly two months. It burned more than 350,000 acres. It's over 500 square miles. Putting out a fire that large is a mammoth task. The base camp that Miki met RJ and Kory at, it was like a mini city with a makeshift laundromat, a cafeteria, a mechanic shop, sleep trailers with triple bunk beds. Like most people at the camp, Kory and RJ work 16-hour days. And they sleep right on the asphalt, right next to where they work in tents they've pitched. They sleep in their uniforms so they can squeeze in a few extra minutes of rest each morning.
米基去访问时，溪火已经持续了近两个月。它烧毁了超过35万英亩的土地，覆盖面积超过500平方英里。扑灭如此大规模的火灾是一项艰巨的任务。米基遇见RJ和科里的那个大本营，就像一个小城市，有临时洗衣房、自助餐厅、修理店、带有三层双层床的睡眠拖车。像营地里的大多数人一样，科里和RJ每天工作16个小时。他们就在工作地点旁边的帐篷里睡在沥青地上。他们穿着制服睡觉，这样每天早上可以多挤出几分钟休息时间。
I was curious. What do you guys dream about at night?
我很好奇。你们晚上梦见什么？
[LAUGHS] My dream yesterday was about hoses. It was about rolling hoses. I was so mad. Like, oh, I can't take no breaks, no days off.
[笑] 我昨天梦见的是水管。梦见在卷水管。我太生气了。就像，噢，我不能休息，没有休息日。
But the thing about RJ and Kory, they love their jobs, despite the repetitiveness and exhaustion. Before this, RJ worked retail and at a car wash. Kory had an office job coding. Now it feels like they're part of something important. They're team captains for their crew, and they have this can-do attitude that it's actually kind of the culture of this camp.
但RJ和科里热爱他们的工作，尽管工作重复且劳累。在此之前，RJ做过零售和洗车。科里做过代码办公室工作。现在，他们感觉自己是某件重要事情的一部分。他们是小组的队长，有一种“能行”的态度，这实际上是这个营地的文化。
I just make sure that the crew's PMA is always at its highest.
我只是确保团队的PMA（积极心态）始终保持在最高水平。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
Positive Mental Attitude.
积极心态（Positive Mental Attitude）。
(SUBJCET) KORY ROVY: Me and Ricky will say something like, hey, yeah, just keep the PMA up.
科里·罗维：我和瑞奇会说些类似的话，嘿，没错，保持积极心态。
Is that a well-known acronym?
这是一个众所周知的缩写吗？
Yes.
是的。
I had never heard of that acronym. I could use some more PMA in my life right now.
我以前从未听说过这个缩写。我现在的生活中可能需要更多的PMA。
With the fire season running longer than ever, it's seven or eight months out of the year now. There's this entire ecosystem of people like RJ and Kory who swoop in and live in fire camps for months all over the west. Today on our program, we meet the people putting these fires out, doing all kinds of jobs you never think of to do it in this unusual situation where they have to push the same boulder up the same hill every single day.
随着火灾季节比以往任何时候都长，现在一年中有七八个月都在发生火灾。存在一个由像RJ和科里这样的人组成的生态系统，他们涌入并居住在西部的火灾营地中，长达数月。今天在节目中，我们见到了那些扑灭火灾的人，他们做了各种你从未想过要做的任务，在这样一种不寻常的情况下，他们必须每天把同一块巨石推上同一座山。
And in the second half of the program, we have a different large group of people who are battling a different large sort of threat. And the stakes could not be higher. They're literally trying to save the world. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在节目的后半部分，我们有一群不同的大型群体，他们正在对抗另一种巨大的威胁。赌注高得不能再高了。他们实际上是在试图拯救世界。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续关注我们。
Act One, The Extinguishers. So we heard about these fire camps from Lizzie Johnson. She's a reporter with the San Francisco Chronicle and spends most of the year chasing fires around California, covering them, and knows so much about them. She took Miki and one of our other producers, Lilly Sullivan, to the fire camp at Creek Fire and has these stories of the people there and what they do and of daily life in this place. Here's Lizzie.
第一幕，灭火者。我们从莉齐·约翰逊（Lizzie Johnson）那里听说了这些消防营地。她是《旧金山纪事报》的记者，一年中大部分时间都在加州各地追逐火灾，进行报道，对火灾非常了解。她带着米基和我们的另一位制片人莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）去了溪火营地，讲述了那里的人们的故事，他们做什么，以及这个地方的日常生活。这是莉齐。
The drive up to the Creek Fire base camp should have been beautiful. This is Ansel Adams country in the High Sierra. But the two-laned highway was lined with trees that looked like charcoal toothpicks. We passed houses where the only thing still standing were the chimneys. The local gas station reminded me of a Salvador Dalí painting. The letters on the big sign out front had melted, dripping down like icicles.
前往溪火大本营的路本应该是美丽的。这是高塞拉安塞尔·亚当斯（Ansel Adams）的领地。但这条双车道公路上排满了看起来像炭火牙签一样的树木。我们经过了一些房子，唯一站立着的东西是烟囱。当地的加油站让我想起萨尔瓦多·达利的画。前面大标志上的字母已经融化了，像冰柱一样滴下来。
I've been to dozens of fire camps. At the big ones, there's always a stand selling T-shirts printed with the year and the name of the fire. And you see firefighters wearing them. There's a predictable rhythm to daily life at these camps. They start with a briefing right at 7:00 AM. This is where everyone gets their orders. At the Creek Fire, this happens by the ski lift.
我去过几十个消防营地。在大的营地里，总有一个摊位卖印有年份和火灾名称的T恤。你会看到消防员穿着它们。这些营地的日常生活节奏是可以预测的。他们早上7点准时进行简报。这是每个人接到命令的地方。在溪火，这发生在滑雪缆车旁。
Quick roll call. Little T.
快速点名。Little T。
Here.
到。
Groveland.
格罗夫兰（Groveland）。
Here.
到。
Grayback 17.
Grayback 17。
Here.
到。
Over 100 firefighters are here. They looked cold, tired, wearing thick stocking caps and heavy jackets. Hundreds more are listening on the radio. This was day 48 of their fight against the Creek Fire.
这里有100多名消防员。他们看起来很冷，很累，穿着厚厚的针织帽和厚外套。还有数百人在收音机里听着。这是他们对抗溪火的第48天。
Plan on your same work assignments today. We're just really controlling that perimeter and making sure nothing moves on us.
今天的任务安排不变。我们只是在控制周边，确保火势不会移动。
There's no way to put out a fire this big, so the best they can do is stop it from growing. The actual mechanics of that feels surprisingly primitive. Hundreds of crews spread out all along the fire's edge, working on their own little speck of land, scraping the ground down to mineral dirt with chainsaws and shovels and bulldozers, so there's nothing left to burn when the wildfire gets there.
没有办法扑灭这么大的火，所以他们能做的最好的事情就是阻止它蔓延。其背后的机械原理感觉相当原始。数百个小组沿着火势蔓延的边缘散开，在各自的一小块土地上工作，用链锯、铲子和推土机将地面刮到矿质土壤，这样当野火到达时，就没有东西可以燃烧了。
So be flexible is kind of a key to it. If something changes where we need to move equipment around, that's kind of some of our reasoning for not getting rid of a ton of stuff yet. Because I know you guys are kind of getting Groundhog Day out there.
所以保持灵活性是关键。如果需要调动设备，这就是我们还没有清理掉大量东西的原因之一。因为我知道你们在那里有点像《土拨鼠日》。
A lot of the top brass, the incident command team, spoke to the firefighters through two flat screen TVs set up on a platform. They were at a command post more than an hour away. To me, it sounded like a county fair.
许多高级官员，即事件指挥团队，通过架在平台上的两台平板电视向消防员发表讲话。他们在一小时路程外的指挥所。对我来说，这听起来像个乡村集市。
All right, thanks, John. Next up, fire behavior. Patty Johnson.
好的，谢谢，约翰。接下来，火灾行为。帕蒂·约翰逊（Patty Johnson）。
Morning. The most growth yesterday was out in this Edison Lake area, mainly closer to the South Fork out here than any place else. Just for the folks in the field, lots of heavy fuels burning out there, lots of smoke coming out of it. So make sure you take breaks with your being in the smoke every day. Probably for some folks, it's 24 hours of smoke that they are experiencing out there. Have a good day.
早上好。昨天火势增长最猛的是爱迪生湖（Edison Lake）地区，主要比其他任何地方都更靠近南岔口（South Fork）。对于现场的工作人员，那里燃烧着许多重燃料，冒出大量浓烟。所以请确保你在每天待在烟雾中时进行休息。对某些人来说，他们可能正在经历24小时的烟雾。祝你们今天过得愉快。
All right, thanks, Patty. For safety--
好的，谢谢，帕蒂。为了安全——
A thick shroud of gray smoke hung over the base camp. The people at the center of the operation are the hotshot crews. They're the most elite of the wildland firefighters, dispatched to the hottest and the farthest corners of the blaze. In the social hierarchy of fire camps, the hotshot crews are at the top.
厚厚的灰色烟雾笼罩着大本营。行动的核心人物是“热点（hotshot）”小组。他们是野外消防员中的精英，被派往火势最猛、距离最远的角落。在消防营地的社会等级中，热点小组处于顶端。
After the morning briefing, I talked to Pete Rosas in the parking lot. He is a squad boss for a hot crew out of LA County. His wife's also a wildland firefighter on a different crew. She drives a water truck called the tender. He told me that in the last month, they'd only overlapped at home one day, which was challenging with a two-year-old daughter.
晨报后，我在停车场采访了皮特·罗萨斯（Pete Rosas）。他是洛杉矶县一支热点小组的队长。他的妻子也是不同小组的野外消防员。她驾驶一辆名为“补给车”的水车。他告诉我，过去一个月里，他们在家里只见过一天，这对于一个两岁女儿的家庭来说很有挑战性。
We bounce back and forth between my family, her family, and daycare.
我们在我的家人、她的家人和日托之间来回奔波。
Pete, Pete, Pete, Pete, Pete.
皮特，皮特，皮特，皮特，皮特。
That's a bunch of young guys from his crew, sticking their heads out the windows of their sherbet green bus-- it's called a buggy-- chirping, "Pete, Pete, Pete." The phoenix is their crew logo.
那是他小组的一群年轻人，从他们果子露绿色的巴士——被称为“小虫子”——的窗户里探出头来，叫着“皮特，皮特，皮特”。凤凰是他们的队徽。
He's the head phoenix, and we're just little birds.
他是领头凤凰，我们只是小鸟。
How many times a day do you hear that?
你一天听多少次？
Oh, man. It's pretty constant.
哦，伙计。几乎是持续不断的。
Do you like when they do that?
你喜欢他们这样做吗？
I mean, not that I like it or look forward to it, but I think, for me, it tells me, OK, the guys are good. They're happy right now. So maybe sometimes when I don't hear it, OK, yeah, what's going on? You guys are up to something.
我是说，并不是我喜欢或期待它，但我认为，对我来说，这告诉我，好的，伙计们很好。他们现在很高兴。所以也许有时当我听不到这个声音时，我就想，好的，怎么了？你们在搞什么鬼。
Pete's crew is called Little Tujunga or Little T for short. At 42, Pete's been on the crew the longest. Some of the younger guys joke that he hatched from an egg at the fire station and keeps them all safe under his wing. Pete's not just their boss, he's a life coach, a mentor, and a therapist all rolled into one, giving them advice on everything from how to clean their chainsaws to buying their first house. He even reminds them to pay their bills back at home.
皮特的团队叫Little Tujunga，简称Little T。42岁的皮特是团队里资历最深的。一些年轻的队员开玩笑说，他是从消防站的一个蛋里孵出来的，并把他们都保护在他的翅膀下。皮特不仅是他们的老板，还是生活教练、导师和心理咨询师，为他们提供从如何清洁链锯到购买第一套房子的建议。他甚至提醒他们回家后付账单。
I feel sometimes like I am their dad. The reason it's like that because I'm with them so much more than I am with my own family. It's like I know what makes them go off, what doesn't, how to calm them down, how to rile them up when we need them to be.
我有时觉得我就是他们的爸爸。之所以这样，是因为我和他们在一起的时间远多于和我的家人在一起。就像我知道什么会让他们发火，什么不会，如何让他们平静下来，当我们需要时如何煽动他们。
Pete's on the shorter side. He's got skull tattoos on his arms to remind himself that death's part of life. The crew knows him for his cool head. He keeps a book called The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck in the side compartment of his truck. He grew up on the east side of LA, still lives there.
皮特个子偏矮。他手臂上有骷髅纹身，提醒自己死亡是生活的一部分。团队因他的冷静而了解他。他在卡车的侧隔间里放了一本名为《不予理会之精妙艺术》（The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck）的书。他在洛杉矶东区长大，至今仍住在那儿。
As a kid, Pete says he never went camping or hiking, never even visited the mountains. He ended up in this job on a total fluke. Back in the early 2000s, the Forest Service was trying to hire more people of color.
小时候，皮特说他从来没去过露营或远足，甚至从来没去过山上。他纯属偶然地进入了这份工作。2000年代初，林务局试图雇用更多有色人种。
I remember it came out in The LA Times and it said, "Hiring 500 firefighters." It was, like, front page. And so, all my buddies came to me. I was the guy with the car. Like, hey, can you take us to this? Drop us off. You know we want to go. I ended up taking them. I ended up staying with them a couple hours in line. I put in an application. So I think a month and a half later, I get a call from the Stanislaus National Forrest offering me an apprenticeship. And the rest is history, I guess.
我记得那是在《洛杉矶时报》上，上面写着“招聘500名消防员”。那就像头版头条。所以，我所有的伙伴都来找我。我是那个有车的人。就像，嘿，你能带我们去这儿吗？把我们放下。你知道我们想去。最后我带了他们。我在排队的地方陪了他们几个小时。我提交了一份申请。所以我想一个半月后，我接到了斯坦尼斯劳斯国家森林的电话，提供给我一个学徒职位。我想剩下的就是历史了。
Little T is now majority Latino with a lot of first generation firefighters like Pete, kids of immigrants. Here's a typical day for the hotshots at camp. After that morning briefing, they load onto their buggies with backpacks crammed with chainsaw fuel, tools, and water. Their packs can weigh up to 50 pounds. They even carry their own stretcher because if one of them gets hurt, they're on their own. They then drive out on a narrow backcountry road, pull up alongside a mountain, and start hiking in the wilderness. It's a brutal 2.8 mile trek to their job site. No trail, no switchbacks, no signposts. They had to keep going back there for two weeks. Here's one of the rookies on Little T, Zach Hanson.
Little T现在大多数是拉美裔，有很多像皮特一样的第一代消防员，移民的孩子。这是营地热点小组的典型一天。晨报后，他们背着装满链锯燃料、工具和水的背包爬上巴士。他们的包重达50磅。他们甚至自己带着担架，因为如果其中一个人受伤，他们就得靠自己。然后，他们沿着狭窄的偏远公路行驶，把车停在山边，开始在荒野中跋涉。去工作地点的路程长达2.8英里。没有小径，没有折返点，没有路标。他们必须连续两周回到那里。这是Little T的新手之一，扎克·汉森（Zach Hanson）。
[(SUBJECT) ZACH HANSON: Every day, you're like, we're doing it again? Again, we got to go up there? And there is about a foot of ash the whole time on the ground and your foot sinking into the ground. And then, there's rocks under the ash. So your boots are getting torn up on these big boulders. But the ash is probably the biggest part because you're just constantly breathing in ash.
扎克·汉森：每天你都想，我们又要做一遍？又要上去？地面上一直有大约一英尺厚的灰烬，你的脚陷进地里。灰烬下面有岩石。所以你的靴子在这些巨大的巨石上被磨坏了。但灰烬可能是最大的部分，因为你一直不停地吸入灰烬。
They're not issued protective breathing gear. And smoke exposure may be why cancer rates are higher among firefighters.
他们没有发放防护呼吸装备。烟雾接触可能是消防员癌症发病率较高的原因。
I mean, for me, when I got to the top, I was spitting black. And when you're pushing at a pace hard like that, I was breathing out of my mouth most of the time, which you try not to do, but I was doing it. And so, my teeth were black. Everything was black. The whole crew was coughing like they had smoked cigarettes their whole life. I think we accepted it at some point. This is our life now, so we'll just keep going up there.
对我来说，当我到达顶部时，我吐出来的是黑色的。当你那样拼命冲刺时，我大部分时间是用嘴呼吸的，你尽量不去这样做，但我还是做了。所以，我的牙齿是黑的。一切都是黑的。整个团队都在咳嗽，就像抽了一辈子烟一样。我想我们在某个时候接受了它。这就是我们现在的生活，所以我们还是会继续上去。
Every single day, they had to return to the same area, a little patch of the Creek Fire about six miles long. The flames were threatening to blow out into a new part of the forest. The air was so smoky that planes couldn't get in to do regular water drops. So for most of their 16-hour workday, Little T revved up their chainsaws and sliced down burning trees.
他们每天都必须回到同一个地区，那是一小片大约6英里长的溪火区域。火焰正威胁着要冲向森林的新区域。空气太烟雾缭绕，飞机无法进入进行常规的水投放。因此，在他们16小时工作日的大部分时间里，Little T发动链锯，砍伐燃烧的树木。
No! Woo! Woo! Woo. Woop woop.
不！呜！呜！呜。呜呜。
They cleared huge piles of brush and branches with their hands and scraped out a dirt path with what are essentially common gardening tools-- rakes, hoes, axes. This path can be up to 30 feet wide. The goal is to give the fire no place to go. Sometimes they literally fight fire with fire, torching trees and brush before the wildfire can get there. They have one of those jobs that's both monotonous and super dangerous.
他们用手清理了大量的灌木和树枝，并用本质上是普通园艺工具——耙子、锄头、斧头——刮出一条土路。这条路宽可达30英尺。目标是不给火势任何地方可去。有时他们确实以火灭火，在野火到达之前烧掉树木和灌木。他们有一份既单调又极其危险的工作。
All the while, they have to be on the lookout for falling trees, called snags. They're one of the ways that hotshots get killed in the fields. Little T ran into a lot of snags their first few days on the Creek Fire. Here's one of the guys on the crew, Frank Plasencia Jr.
与此同时，他们必须提防倒下的树木，称为“障碍木（snags）”。这是热点小组在野外丧生的一种方式。Little T在溪火的前几天遇到了很多障碍木。这是团队里的一员，弗兰克·普拉森西亚（Frank Plasencia Jr.）。
Your heart's pumping. Your adrenaline's pumping. You're scared, you're worried, you're nervous. We yell, "snag," or "tree," and we all have to bail out. And you can't control it. You could be just walking by a tree and just boop, and it falls. Big or small, they'll go.
你的心脏在跳动。你的肾上腺素在分泌。你害怕，你担心，你紧张。我们大喊“障碍木”或“树”，我们所有人就得逃命。你无法控制它。你可能只是路过一棵树，然后砰的一声，它就倒下了。无论大小，它们都会倒。
When trees are falling, what does that sound like?
当树木倒下时，那听起来像什么？
It's a loud crack. It feels suspenseful because you don't know where it's coming because you're surrounded by trees. If it's a big tree, it's a big boom.
那是一声巨响。这让人感到悬念，因为你不知道它来自哪里，因为你被树木包围了。如果是大树，那就是一声巨响。
It shakes the ground. It'll shake the ground. And so, you feel that. Yeah, it's not a good feeling. It's definitely not a good feeling.
它会震动地面。它会震动地面。所以，你能感觉到。是的，那不是一种好的感觉。这绝对不是一种好的感觉。
Again, here's Pete, who's been hotshotting for more than a decade.
再一次，这是皮特，他已经做热点队员十多年了。
There's been trees that have fallen right where I was standing, literally within seconds of me taking three steps. Like, fuck, that literally could have been it. OK, I got to clear my mind of this because I got the rest of the assignment or the rest of my career to think about, so I can't dwell on that. But fuck, man, that was close. That could have been it.
有些树直接倒在我站的地方，就在我走开三步后的几秒钟内。就像，该死，那真的可能就是终点了。好的，我必须把这些清理出我的脑子，因为我还有剩下的任务或剩下的职业生涯要考虑，所以我不能沉溺于此。但该死，伙计，那太接近了。那可能就是终点了。
There's so many ways you can get hurt or die on a wildfire. Firefighters get cut by chainsaws, crushed by boulders, and into car wrecks on dirt roads. Little T was once in a fire where a plane accidentally dumped thousands of gallons of flame retardant on a firefighter from another crew, killing him.
在野火中受伤或死亡的方式太多了。消防员被链锯割伤，被巨石压碎，在土路上发生车祸。Little T曾经历过一次火灾，一架飞机不小心向另一组的消防员倾倒了数千加仑的阻燃剂，导致他死亡。
And then, earlier this season, a squad boss like Pete died while fighting the El Dorado fire in Southern California. The flames burned over him. Afterward, another member of the crew who'd been upset about his death went missing. Suicide and PTSD have risen among wildland firefighters.
然后，在本赛季早些时候，像皮特这样的一位小组长在南加州扑灭埃尔多拉多（El Dorado）火灾时丧生。火焰烧过他。事后，另一名对他的死感到不安的队员失踪了。野外消防员中的自杀和PTSD有所增加。
It feels like dumb luck that Pete hasn't seen a death on his own crew. He's in charge of a bunch of guys in their 20s. A lot of them are pretty new to this job. Pete can't stop worrying even when they're off the fire and get to go home. He says they've gotten injured and even died in car accidents, tired and in a rush to get home after a fire. I've heard a lot of firefighters talk about this is a problem. Pete says his wife Jen sometimes busts him for not being able to leave the guys back at work.
皮特自己的团队没有发生死亡事件，感觉纯属运气。他负责一群20多岁的年轻人。他们很多人对这份工作很陌生。皮特即使在他们离开火线回家时也无法停止担忧。他说他们因疲劳和急着在火灾后回家而在车祸中受伤甚至死亡。我听到很多消防员谈论这是一个问题。皮特说他的妻子珍有时会责备他无法在工作后离开这些小伙子。
Sometimes I get this blank stare. And then we're sitting on the couch, right? I don't watch TV, but Jen was watching TV. And she'll look at me. And right away, her question always is, are you thinking about work? Are you thinking about the guys?
有时我会陷入这种空洞的凝视。然后我们坐在沙发上，对吧？我不看电视，但珍在看电视。她会看着我。她的第一个问题总是：你在想工作吗？你在想那些小伙子吗？
[INAUDIBLE] what are you thinking, wanting a romantic answer, and you're like, I'm thinking about Frank. [LAUGHS]
——你在想什么，想要一个浪漫的答案，而你却说，我在想弗兰克。[笑]
Yeah, honestly, that does happen, you know? What are they doing right now? Like, oh, I wonder if do they need help. I don't want them to get hurt. I want to get back really.
是的，老实说，确实发生了，你知道吗？他们现在在做什么？就像，哦，我不知道他们是否需要帮助。我不想让他们受伤。我真的想回去。
I'm curious. Because you spend so much time with these guys, does it ever feel easier to be more like a dad to them than to your own children, who you don't get to see very often?
我很好奇。因为你花这么多时间和这些小伙子在一起，对待他们是否比对待你自己的孩子更容易，因为你不常常见到他们？
Yeah, definitely. I mean, I don't know how to answer that other than, yeah, it is like that, unfortunately, I guess. Because I do see sometimes a difference in how I treat everybody in my family and how I treat these guys sometimes. More understanding and more patient. We're literally stuck with each other for seven, eight months out of the year. If the guys get in an argument or are not seeing eye to eye, you can't just walk away. You have to deal with it at the moment, or it could potentially cost us our lives.
是的，绝对。我的意思是，我不知道该怎么回答，除了说，是的，确实是这样，不幸的是，我想。因为我确实有时看到我对待家里每个人和我对待这些小伙子之间有差异。更理解，更耐心。我们一年中有七八个月实际上被困在一起。如果小伙子们争吵或看法不一致，你不能直接走开。你必须在当下处理它，否则它可能会危及我们的生命。
With the family, you walk away. And you'll come back a day later or whatever it be. With us, you can't. So I'm aware that it might be unfair. I'm 100% aware of that.
如果是家人，你会走开。然后你会一天后再回来什么的。对我们来说，你不能。所以我意识到这可能是不公平的。我100%意识到这一点。
Long fire seasons are now so consistent that there's a whole army of private contractors that chases these fires across California, too. It's a multimillion dollar industry. Their jobs are to make life a little easier for the people out on the fire line.
漫长的火灾季节现在变得如此稳定，以至于有一整支私人承包商军队也在加州追逐这些火灾。这是一个价值数百万美元的行业。他们的工作是让火线上的生活变得轻松一点。
At the Creek Fire, most of these contractors are set up in the main parking lot of the ski resort, which is the equivalent of downtown here. There's hot showers, the sleep trailers-- they're highly sought after-- and an industrial kitchen that packs up these brown paper bag lunches called the 5,000 calorie meal. The mobile laundromat is in a white trailer in the back of the parking lot, hooked up to a water tank. It has 16 washers and dryers going all the time.
在溪火，大多数这些承包商都设在滑雪场的停车场，这相当于这里的市中心。有热水淋浴，睡眠拖车——它们非常抢手——以及一个工业厨房，打包这些名为“5000卡路里餐”的棕色纸袋午餐。移动洗衣房位于停车场后面的一个白色拖车里，连接着一个水箱。它有16台洗衣机和烘干机一直在运转。
Is this one dirty, too?
这件也脏吗？
Oh, yeah, right.
哦，是的，对了。
Jenn Wolf is the person in charge of washing everyone's filthy laundry. She says Little T always texts her the second they get off the mountain, just so they can jump to the front of the line as soon as they roll back into camp.
詹·沃尔夫（Jenn Wolf）负责清洗所有人的肮脏衣物。她说Little T每次一下山就会给她发短信，这样他们就能在回到营地时排在队首。
Put a little detergent in there. There we go.
加点洗涤剂。好了。
How many loads of laundry do you do in a day?
你一天洗多少衣服？
About 460. Yeah, could be more. We're either working or sleeping, basically. There's no real downtime.
大约460袋。是的，可能更多。我们基本上不是在工作就是在睡觉。没有真正的休息时间。
Jenn wears blue latex gloves so she doesn't pick up poison oak.
詹戴着蓝色乳胶手套，这样就不会碰到毒橡树。
Does it smell really bad when it comes in?
送过来的时候闻起来很臭吗？
It can. Some of these teams, what's called a spike out--
可能会。其中一些团队，所谓的“扎营（spike out）”——
Spiking out means camping out in a remote spot near the fire line.
扎营意味着在火线附近的偏远地点露营。
And they spike out there for sometimes two weeks. And there's no laundry service, no shower. And yeah, their socks can stand on their own sometimes. [LAUGHS]
他们在那里扎营有时长达两周。没有洗衣服务，没有淋浴。是的，他们的袜子有时能自己站起来。[笑]
One of the guys who works for her was a lot less diplomatic.
为她工作的一个人外交辞令少多了。
So if you go to this grocery store, you buy 12 eggs, you boil them, and now you leave them out for a month, that's what some of these clothes smell like.
所以如果你去超市买12个鸡蛋，煮了它们，然后把它们放上一个月，这就是其中一些衣服闻起来的味道。
The only snafu Jenn had here at camp was a sock mix-up. She accidentally put one firefighter's expensive wool socks in another guy's bags.
詹在营地里遇到的唯一麻烦是袜子混淆了。她不小心把一个消防员昂贵的羊毛袜放进了另一个人的袋子里。
And [LAUGHS] we were able to unite the socks first. Sorry.
而且[笑]我们能够先把袜子团聚。抱歉。
Why is that so funny?
为什么这那么好笑？
It just is. [LAUGHS] Well, he was upset about his socks. But we got them back to him, so all is good.
就是这样。[笑]好吧，他因为袜子很生气。但我们把它们还给了他，所以一切都好。
How long did the sock saga last?
袜子传奇持续了多久？
Um, I think a couple of days. So yeah, it was very high stress. It's socks, but you know what? I'm telling you, that is the comforts. They were his socks. He wanted them back.
嗯，我想几天吧。所以是的，压力很大。这是袜子，但你知道吗？我告诉你，那是舒适所在。那是他的袜子。他想拿回去。
The Creek is the fourth fire camp Jenn has worked at this year. She says the smoke in each of them smells really different. Here, it's like a campfire from all the smoldering pine trees. But in more populated areas where buildings and houses burn, the smoke smells synthetic and greasy. It stings your lungs. That reminded me of the fires I saw in wine country in 2017. More than 5,000 houses and buildings burned down. The smoke smelled awful because you were breathing in people's lives.
溪火是詹今年工作的第四个火灾营地。她说每个营地的烟味闻起来真的非常不同。在这里，就像所有阴燃的松树发出的篝火味。但在人口稠密的地区，建筑物和房屋燃烧时，烟味闻起来是合成的、油腻的。它刺痛你的肺。这让我想起了我在2017年酒乡看到的火灾。超过5000所房屋和建筑物被烧毁。烟味很可怕，因为你呼吸的是人们的生活。
Kaylee Ralls has one of the most important jobs in the camp. She works in a trailer, printing the maps and action plans for all the teams. The printers run 24 hours a day, and Kaylee is the only person on her 12-hour shift, so she can't leave the trailer. People are constantly running in and out. They never have time to chat, which means that this person who everyone relies on is the loneliest person I met at camp.
凯莉·拉尔斯（Kaylee Ralls）在营地里有一份最重要的工作。她在拖车里工作，为所有团队打印地图和行动计划。打印机24小时运转，而凯莉是她12小时轮班中唯一的人，所以她不能离开拖车。人们不停地跑进跑出。他们从来没有时间聊天，这意味着每个人都依赖的这个人是我在营地里见过的最孤独的人。
The most exciting drama that had happened the week I was there was a black bear busting into a giant grease spot from the kitchen. The cook told me the bear had chugged about 100 gallons of grease. But as usual, that news hadn't reached Kaylee yet.
我待的那周发生的最令人兴奋的戏码是一头黑熊闯进了厨房的一个巨大油脂池。厨师告诉我，那头熊喝了大约100加仑的油脂。但像往常一样，那个消息还没有传到凯莉那里。
Have you seen the bear?
你看到那头熊了吗？
The bear?
那头熊？
It's been eating the bacon grease.
它一直在吃培根油。
No way! I never even heard of this! I'm like in the dark over here. I'm not even kidding. No one tells me anything. Any time I get any juicy info, I'm like, no way. No one talks to me. I'm all alone over here.
没可能！我甚至没听说过！我在这里就像与世隔绝。我真没开玩笑。没人告诉我任何事。每当我得到任何有趣的信息，我都想，没可能。没人跟我说话。我一个人在这里。
Kaylee says the only time she leaves her trailer, called Firedog, is to go out to the porta potty. She's so isolated that she hasn't even figured out how to read the map she's printing. They're typographic and color-coded to show where the fire's the hottest, with symbols for all the different teams. At this point, the outline of the fire perimeter kind of looks like a Sasquatch with its front leg kicked out.
凯莉说她离开她的拖车——叫Firedog——的唯一一次是去流动厕所。她如此与世隔绝，以至于她甚至没学会如何看她正在打印的地图。它们是排版的，并按颜色编码，显示哪里火势最猛，并带有所有不同团队的符号。在这一点上，火灾周边的轮廓看起来有点像脚印大脚怪，前腿踢了出来。
Kaylee's 20. She wears a hoodie and has perfect makeup. She recently broke up with her long time boyfriends. But she explained to one of my producers, Lilly Sullivan, that there's a rule at camp.
凯莉20岁。她穿着连帽衫，化着完美的妆。她最近和交往很久的男朋友分手了。但她向我的制片人之一莉莉·沙利文解释说，营地里有一条规定。
So basically, you can't be macking on these boys and doing that. That's our policy.
基本上，你不能在这里泡这些小伙子，做那种事。那是我们的政策。
It's an actual policy.
这确实是一项政策。
It's an actual policy. We sign it. We have to keep it professional.
这是一项真正的政策。我们签了字。我们必须保持职业。
Yeah, you have a job to do.
是的，你有工作要做。
Yep, exactly. We have a job to do. But yeah, the view is great, you know? Not necessarily here, but. [LAUGHS] Every fire is different.
是的，没错。我们有工作要做。但，视野很好，你知道吗？不一定在这里，但是。[笑]每一场火灾都是不同的。
You don't think there are other cute people here?
你不觉得这里还有其他可爱的人吗？
Mm, I'm trying to think. No. Fed fires usually don't have cute people. Tend to be older and yeah.
嗯，我想想。没有。联邦火灾通常没有可爱的人。往往年纪更大，是的。
Fed fires-- meaning fire camps run by the US Forest Service. But camps run by the state's agency, CAL FIRE?
联邦火灾——意味着由美国林务局运营的消防营地。但由州政府机构CAL FIRE运营的营地呢？
CAL FIRES-- that's where it's at. That's where it's at. CAL FIRES have cute boys. Say I get a call, and he says, I'm sending you here, it's going to be a CAL FIRE. I'm like sweet. Every girl on our team would be like, awesome.
CAL FIRE——那才是重点。那才是重点。CAL FIRE有可爱的男孩。假设我接到一个电话，他说，我要把你派到那里，那将是CAL FIRE。我就会说甜。我们团队里的每个女孩都会觉得，太棒了。
Because what's the difference?
因为有什么区别？
The CAL FIRE, I don't know what it is, but there's always younger-- and even when they're not. I don't know if it's because they have nice uniforms, and they have to be really clean-like. It's nicer all around. Not only because there's cute boys, but because you get better food. It's like, if you're going to stay at this five star hotel compared to this three star type thing. So CAL FIRE is the five star hotel. Fed fire's like three.
CAL FIRE，我不知道是什么，但总是有更年轻的——即使他们不是。我不知道是不是因为他们有漂亮的制服，而且他们必须非常干净。各方面都更好。不仅因为有可爱的男孩，还因为你有更好的食物。就像，如果你要住在这家五星级酒店相比这种三星级酒店。所以CAL FIRE是五星级酒店。联邦火灾就像三星级。
Kaylee doesn't actually sleep at the camp. Her company rented her a cabin about 30 minutes away. But it's the worst part of the job. It's creepy, she says. The curtains on her bedroom windows are see-through.
凯莉实际上并没有睡在营地。她的公司为她租了一个大约30分钟路程的小木屋。但这是工作中最好的一点。她说这很令人毛骨悚然。她卧室窗户上的窗帘是透明的。
Did you get some sleep last night? [INAUDIBLE]
昨晚睡着了吗？
Yeah, I was on FaceTime with my mom all night.
是的，我整晚都在和妈妈FaceTime。
All night?
整晚？
We set it up, and then we go to bed. [LAUGHS]
我们设置好，然后我们就去睡觉。[笑]
Wait, so you put your mom on FaceTime, and you guys go to bed. You sleep like that?
等等，所以你把妈妈放在FaceTime上，你们去睡觉了。你们那样睡觉？
Yeah. We're usually not in creepy places, but this just happened to be creepy. When I get back to the cabin, I FaceTime her, and we'll talk all night. And then I'm like, OK, let's set up our phones. And she's like, OK. So we literally fall asleep. If I open my eyes, I can look at my phone and see her. And I just wake up all throughout the night and look to see if she's still there.
是的。我们通常不会在令人毛骨悚然的地方，但这种情况正好令人毛骨悚然。当我回到小木屋时，我给她FaceTime，我们会聊整晚。然后我会说，好吧，让我们设置好手机。她说，好吧。所以我们确实睡着了。如果我睁开眼睛，我可以看手机看她。我整晚都在醒来，看她是否还在那里。
Does she sleep with the light on so that you can see her?
她睡觉时开着灯，这样你就能看到她吗？
No, I sleep with the light on. And [LAUGHS] so she can see me because I feel like there's something there. And then my alarm goes off in the morning. She's like, Kaylee, wake up. Yeah.
不，我睡觉开着灯。而且[笑]这样她就能看到我，因为我觉得那里有什么东西。然后我早上闹钟响了。她说，凯莉，醒醒。是的。
Kaylee is thinking about moving out of her cabin and into a tent at the camp, just so she doesn't have to feel so alone.
凯莉正在考虑搬出她的小木屋，住进营地的帐篷里，这样她就不必感到那么孤独了。
It can be weirdly easy to work on these wildfires and not think about the big picture at all. This year was a turning point. The combination of climate change, drought, dead and diseased trees and more housing built in high risk places. California saw six of the state's biggest fires in modern history. For the first time, firefighters began using the term giga fire to describe a million acres burning.
在这些野火中工作却完全不考虑大局，这在某种程度上是非常容易的。今年是一个转折点。气候变化、干旱、枯死和患病的树木以及在易受火灾影响的地区建造更多住房的综合影响。加州见证了该州历史上六场最大的火灾。消防员第一次开始使用“千兆火（giga fire）”一词来描述燃烧的一百万英亩土地。
We still approach wildfires with a very manifest destiny type of attitude, believing that with enough people and grit, there's no fire we can't conquer. But we've spent four months and almost $200 million on the Creek Fire, and it's still not out. The Creek Fire destroyed 850 homes and businesses. Most of them were in little mountain towns, where nothing will be ever totally normal again, not even the ground. After a big fire, the dirt is toxic from melted insulation and all the other synthetic stuff inside a home when it burns down. And with the forest gutted, you can suddenly see for miles.
我们仍然以一种非常天定命运的态度对待野火，相信只要有足够的人力和勇气，就没有我们无法征服的火灾。但我们在溪火上花了四个月和近2亿美元，它仍然没有扑灭。溪火摧毁了850所房屋和企业。大多数位于小山城，那里的一切将永远不会完全正常，甚至土地也是如此。在大火之后，土壤因为房屋烧毁时内部的绝缘材料和所有其他合成物质而变得有毒。随着森林被掏空，你可以突然看到几英里外。
I talked to a bulldozer operator named Dean Mullis, who goes by Woody. He got a glimpse of this and was still thinking about it a few weeks after he'd gone home. On his very first shift on the Creek Fire, he was sent out to protect a neighborhood the fire hadn't reached yet. It was on Cressman Road. He'd never been here before.
我采访了一位名叫迪恩·穆利斯（Dean Mullis）的推土机操作员，他叫伍迪（Woody）。他看到了这一点，并在他回家几周后仍在思考它。在溪火的第一班，他被派去保护火还没有到达的一个社区。那是在克雷斯曼路（Cressman Road）。他以前从未来过这里。
All of a sudden, there's just fire. You don't exactly know where to go.
突然之间，到处都是火。你不知道具体该往哪走。
So he started pushing away anything that might cause the houses to catch fire.
所以他开始推开任何可能导致房子着火的东西。
I was basically in the bulldozer pushing cars that were on fire, playground sets, decks, like wooden decks, off the back of a house, brush, trees, kicking that fuel away from those houses.
我基本上在推土机里推那些着火的汽车、游乐场设备、甲板，比如木制甲板，从房子的后面，灌木，树木，把燃料踢离那些房子。
He worked through the night. But most of the homes didn't survive.
他通宵工作。但大多数房子没能幸存下来。
And we'd drive through there, and we'd go, man, why did that one survive and the other one didn't? I don't know.
我们开车穿过那里，我们说，伙计，为什么那一间幸存了而另一间没有？我不知道。
Woody is a dozer operator for the state's CAL FIRE agency. Unlike hotshot crews, he spends most of his time alone, moving huge piles of dirt in his dozer, scraping fuel breaks to get ahead of the flames. He jokes that the stereotype of a bulldozer operator is someone who's kind of salty and will push back against orders they don't agree with.
伍迪是州CAL FIRE机构的推土机操作员。与热点小组不同，他大部分时间都是一个人，在他的推土机里移动巨大的土堆，刮掉燃料隔断以跑在火焰前面。他开玩笑说，推土机操作员的刻板印象是一个有点刻薄的人，会反抗他们不同意的命令。
Woody's bald with piercing blue eyes. He says he hates what the big fire camps like the one at the Creek have become. Once upon a time, when Woody first started, the fire camp was just a few boots in a lot where you went to pick up your paycheck or radio.
伍迪秃头，有一双锐利的蓝色眼睛。他说他讨厌像溪火这样的火灾营地变成了什么样。很久以前，伍迪刚开始时，消防营地只是停车场里的几双靴子，你去那里领取工资或收音机。
You know, it's been a really long fire season. How are you feeling at this point?
你知道，这是一个非常漫长的火灾季节。你现在感觉如何？
I'm not going to-- I don't like it. I don't like it. I mean, it's too much. It's just devastation. You see all the comments on social media, the new norm in California. It sucks. I don't want to be running the bulldozer in December in Southern California, protecting structures. I mean, I will. It's my job. Of course, I will.
我不会——我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我的意思是，太多了。这只是毁灭。你在社交媒体上看到所有的评论，加州的新常态。糟透了。我不想在12月在南加州开推土机，保护建筑物。我的意思是，我会的。这是我的工作。当然，我会的。
But I care for people a lot. And I don't enjoy seeing houses burn. Nobody wants to do that. People want to go to their-- it's the holidays. You're supposed to be staring at Ralphie from A Christmas Story, not staring at a wildfire.
但我非常关心人。我不喜欢看到房子燃烧。没有人想那样做。人们想去他们的——那是节日。你应该盯着《圣诞故事》里的拉尔菲，而不是盯着野火。
I first met Woody in 2018 at another California fire, the Ferguson. It happened north of here. That year, at least six firefighters died. Two of them were dozer operators and included Woody's best friend from childhood. His name is Braden Varney, and he is the one who got Woody into firefighting.
我第一次在2018年加州的另一场火灾——弗格森火灾中见到伍迪。它发生在这里的北部。那一年，至少有六名消防员丧生。其中两人是推土机操作员，包括伍迪童年最好的朋友。他的名字叫布雷登·瓦尼（Braden Varney），他是带伍迪进入消防行业的人。
It was dark. It was extremely steep. And his bulldozer slid off the side of a road, and he perished when it slid. It tumbled down the mountain.
天很黑。非常陡峭。他的推土机从路边滑了下去，他在滑下时丧生了。它翻滚下山。
It took two days for firefighters to retrieve Braden's body. They draped an American flag over his remains and carried him out of the canyon. Now Woody has Braden's job at their local fire station in Mariposa. He sees himself as part of the lineage of dozer operators, one that started with Braden's dad, who held the spot until he died of cancer from the job.
消防员花了整整两天时间才找回布雷登的遗体。他们给他的遗体盖上一面美国国旗，把他抬出了峡谷。现在伍迪在马里波萨当地的消防站做了布雷登的工作。他认为自己是推土机操作员血统的一部分，这一血统始于布雷登的父亲，他一直守着这个岗位直到他因工作导致的癌症去世。
Braden and I always wanted to be partners on the bulldozers. Braden will always be on my mind. Braden will always be with me on the fire lines in the morning, drinking coffee out of a plastic water bottle that's been cut in half out of a homemade coffee pot.
布雷登和我一直想在推土机上做搭档。布雷登永远在我脑海里。布雷登永远会和我在早上的火线上，用半个塑料水瓶做的自制咖啡壶喝咖啡。
Do you ever think about how much longer you can or want to do this job for? Are you counting down the days until retirement?
你有没有想过你还能或者想做这份工作多久？你在倒计时退休的日子吗？
Haha, I'm not one of those guys yet. I still have 19 years left.
哈哈，我还不是那种人。我还有19年。
You have 19 years left?
你有19年？
Yeah, so I started late, so. No, no, no, no. I have 18 years left.
是的，我开始得晚，所以。不，不，不，不。我还有18年。
Eight? That's still a lot of years.
八年？那仍然是很多年。
Well, the retirement formula changed. You used to retire at 50. Now they retire us at 57.
好吧，退休公式变了。你过去50岁退休。现在他们让我们57岁退休。
Do you think you can make it until you're 57?
你觉得你能坚持到57岁吗？
I mean, if you look at a billboard, statistic billboard, if I don't catch cancer, I'm doing pretty good.
我的意思是，如果你看一个广告牌，统计数据广告牌，如果我不患上癌症，我做得很好。
Woody, 18 years. Can you imagine what the fire season will be like in 18 years?
伍迪，18年。你能想象18年后的火灾季节会是什么样吗？
I don't think anything will be left. [LAUGHS]
我不认为还会剩下什么。[笑]
It very well might be that way.
情况很可能就是那样。
I don't know. I mean, that brush grows back.
我不知道。我的意思是，那灌木丛会长回来。
Yeah.
是的。
So I don't know. It's a crazy job sometimes.
所以我不知道。有时这是一份疯狂的工作。
Hey, guys.
嘿，伙计们。
Hey, what's going on?
嘿，发生什么了？
I met up with the Little T hotshots again on their very last night at camp. They were about to get to go home for two days. They stood out from the rest of the scraggly and bearded dirty men in the parking lot. Everyone on Little T was showered, clean shaven. It's a crew tradition. In one of the buggies, the guys were watching a Dodgers game on a little TV.
我在营地的最后一个晚上又遇见了Little T的热点队员。他们很快就能回家待两天了。他们在停车场里与其他衣衫褴褛、胡子拉碴、肮脏的男人中脱颖而出。Little T的每个人都洗了澡，刮了胡子。这是团队传统。在其中一辆车里，小伙子们在小电视上看道奇队的比赛。
They looked relaxed and happy, even though they just heard the fire season might get extended another two months into January. That's something that would have been hard to imagine a few years ago. Again, here's Zach and Frank. Like a lot of the crew, they're contractors who get laid off at the end of the season.
他们看起来轻松快乐，尽管他们刚刚听说火灾季节可能会再延长两个月到一月。那是几年前很难想象的事情。再一次，这是扎克和弗兰克。像团队里的很多人一样，他们是合同工，在赛季结束时会被解雇。
What do you think about the season possibly going all the way until January?
你觉得赛季可能一直持续到一月怎么想？
It's so exciting. We were all excited.
太令人兴奋了。我们都很兴奋。
We were all happy.
我们都很开心。
Yeah. It was funny. When they asked, everybody on this crew's hand shot up.
是的。很有趣。当他们问的时候，这个团队里的每个人都举起了手。
How do you just keep going, on and on and on?
你怎么能就这样一直持续下去，不停地？
Each other. Honestly, each other. Like, the synergy, the family dynamics.
彼此。老实说，彼此。就像，协同作用，家庭动力。
You guys are all positive attitudes.
你们所有人都有积极的态度。
That's mandatory.
那是必须的。
That's mandatory. You cannot have a negative attitude and get away with it here.
那是必须的。你不能在这里有消极的态度还能逃脱惩罚。
I would say this job's probably impossible if you don't have a good attitude.
如果你的态度不好，这份工作可能是不可能的。
But when you're having a really bad day, what do you tell yourself?
但当你度过非常糟糕的一天时，你告诉自己什么？
No bad days. It sounds so weird. And I totally get why it sounds weird, but that's a big thing that we have, is like, no bad days. On the worst day, it's not that bad.
没有糟糕的日子。听起来很奇怪。我完全明白为什么听起来很奇怪，但这是我们有的一个大事情，就是，没有糟糕的日子。在最糟糕的一天，也不是那么糟糕。
It can always be worse.
情况总是会更糟。
We always say, is like, it can always be worse. It could be hotter. It could be a lot--
我们总是说，就像，情况总是会更糟。可能会更热。可能会多——
Steeper.
更陡。
--colder. It could be way steeper.
——更冷。可能会更陡。
The truth is, a lot of people don't last more than a few years at this job. The adrenaline high eventually wears off, and they move on to other jobs, jobs that are easier on their families. One of the hardest parts of hotshotting is just how much they're on the road. More of their life is spent out at fires than at home.
事实是，很多人在这份工作上坚持不了几年。肾上腺素的快感最终会消失，他们会转向其他工作，对家庭更轻松的工作。做热点队员最难的部分之一就是他们一直在路上。他们生命中更多的时间花在火灾现场，而不是家里。
This season, Little T has been on back-to-back assignments since June. Nevada, Utah, Arizona, all up and down California. The way their assignments work is they go out for 14 or 21 days at a time, then only get two days off before shipping out again. With all the overtime, it's good money. One of the chainsaw guys on the crew said he'd make 70,000 after taxes. So some of them don't really work during the off season.
这个赛季，Little T从六月起就一直在连续执行任务。内华达、犹他、亚利桑那，加州上下。他们执行任务的方式是他们一次出动14或21天，然后只有两天假，然后再次出发。加上所有的加班费，钱不错。团队里的一位链锯手说他交税后能赚7万。所以他们中有些人休赛期根本不工作。
While they're out fighting fires, life goes on without them. They're reminded of this in a very literal way. They often go without cell service for days. And then the second they get back in range, they're bombarded by everything they've missed. Joel Gonzales is one of the captains on Little T.
当他们在外面扑灭火灾时，生活在没有他们的情况下继续进行。他们以一种非常字面的方式被提醒这一点。他们经常几天没有手机信号。然后他们一回到信号范围内，就被错过的所有事情轰炸。乔尔·冈萨雷斯（Joel Gonzales）是Little T的队长之一。
Some guys, over 100 messages a day.
有些人，一天超过100条消息。
You're thinking of something. You're thinking about an example.
你在想什么。你在想一个例子。
I'm thinking of someone who's in the truck right now.
我在想现在就在卡车里的某个人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What's the situation?
情况怎么样？
This is a busy year for us. And she doesn't understand that one of my guys, he just can't be on his phone all the time, you know? And then, when he does get service, he finds out how many times she's been messaging him, so.
这是我们忙碌的一年。而她不明白，我的一名队员，他只是不能一直用手机，你知道吗？然后，当他有信号时，他发现她发了多少条信息，所以。
But it's like how many?
但就像是多少？
On the low end, maybe in the 20s. In the high end, maybe over 100.
低端，可能是20多条。高端，可能超过100条。
She's just like, call me. Call me. Where are you? What the fuck? What's going on? You think he'll talk to me about it?
她只是说，打给我。打给我。你在哪？搞什么鬼？什么情况？你认为他会跟我谈吗？
No. [LAUGHS] He won't. I won't throw him under the bus.
不。[笑]他不会。我不会出卖他。
I get a lot, Pete, how come women don't understand what we do? Why doesn't she get it?
我经常接到，皮特，为什么女人不理解我们做什么？为什么她不明白？
Again, here's Pete, the squad boss who gets tripped out by the crew. He says they're constantly asking him for relationship advice. He keeps it pretty simple. Sit down and talk. Put yourself in her shoes. But the problem is, they never actually have time to use it.
再一次，这是皮特，那位被团队折腾的队长。他说他们一直在向他询问人际关系建议。他保持得相当简单。坐下来谈谈。换位思考。但问题是，他们从来没有时间真正使用它。
I could be telling them that today, this morning. But then he never makes it home to be able to do that. And now, it just turns into worse and worse and worse. And unfortunately, it doesn't work. It's really hard to understand or even sometimes believe that you're gone so long or believe that you're on a fire. Or why didn't you have service? Why didn't you have service? I just talked to you a minute ago. Well, yeah, I know, I was hiking, and I had service for one second, and now it's gone. And now they don't hear from you again for three, four days. You can't explain that.
我今天早上可能就在告诉他们。但他从来没能回家做到那一点。现在，它只会变得越来越糟。不幸的是，它不起作用。真的很难理解，甚至有时很难相信你离开了那么久，或者相信你在火灾现场。或者为什么你没有信号？为什么你没有信号？我一分钟前才跟你谈过。嗯，是的，我知道，我在远足，我有一秒钟信号，现在没了。然后你再也没听到你的消息，持续三、四天。你无法解释这一点。
There have already been a couple break ups this season. Pete says his first marriage ended in divorce because he was gone so much. Unlike the seasonal guys, he's year round. He was on a fire when his son was born and this season, missed his daughter's birthday. Pete often scrolls through photos of them on his cell phone.
本赛季已经有几对分手了。皮特说他的第一次婚姻以离婚告终，因为他离开得太多了。不像季节性队员，他是全年的。他儿子出生时他在火灾现场，本赛季，错过了女儿的生日。皮特经常在手机上滚动查看他们的照片。
Get a picture of my boy.
拿一张我儿子的照片。
He showed me one of his son, now 11, competing at a swim meet.
他给我看了一张他儿子现在的照片，11岁，参加游泳比赛。
Was that cool getting to be at his meet?
能参加他的比赛很酷吗？
Oh, yeah. Well, I didn't make it to this one. This is a picture they sent me, but I've been to some of his meets. Not too many, but yeah, it's fun. It's definitely fun watching him.
噢，是的。嗯，这个我没赶上。这是他们发给我的照片，但我参加过他的一些比赛。不多，但是的，很有趣。看他比赛确实很有趣。
Are they always very forgiving of you being gone, not being there for the big things in their life?
他们总是很宽容你离开，没有出现在他们生活中的大事上吗？
I like to say yeah, because I think they don't know any different. They think it's the norm. It's like, oh, Dad's always gone working. I think--
我喜欢说是的，因为我想他们不知道有什么不同。他们认为这是常态。就像，哦，爸爸总是离开去工作。我想——
Good morning, Peter.
早上好，彼得。
Thank you.
谢谢。
One of the guys from his crew stopped by his truck. This happened all the time while I was talking to him.
他团队里的一个小伙子停在他的卡车旁。我跟他谈话时，这经常发生。
OK, I'm sorry. So they brought me my breakfast. They brought me my lunch. It's like the first thing on their plate. OK, we got to take care of Pete, and then we'll do our thing. It becomes to where you become very catered to. Well, this is not normal. In real life, it's not like that. I mean, your kids are going to talk back. Your wife is going to want different things. It's going to be a different type of reaction. And somebody has been doing this so long, somebody like myself and a lot of these other guys. You don't want to deal with that because it's a lot easier here. It's a lot easier.
好的，对不起。所以他们带给我早餐。他们带给我午餐。就像他们盘子里的第一件事。好的，我们必须照顾皮特，然后我们做我们的事。它变得让你变得非常被照顾。嗯，这不是正常的。在现实生活中，不是那样的。我的意思是，你的孩子会回嘴。你的妻子会想要不同的东西。这会是一种不同类型的反应。而一个人做这件事太久了，像我这样的人和其他许多人。你不想处理那个，因为它在这里容易得多。它容易得多。
Pete's the perfect worker for these long fire seasons. He loves his job. And when I asked him if the relentlessness ever gets to him, he told me no. The more fire, the better. The more I work, the more I don't have to think about real life.
皮特是这些漫长火灾季节的完美工人。他热爱他的工作。当我问他这种无情是否会影响他时，他告诉我不。火灾越多越好。我工作得越多，我就越不用思考现实生活。
Lizzie Johnson at The San Francisco Chronicle. She's got a book about the Paradise Fire that's coming out that you can preorder online. The Creek Fire, after burning for nearly four months, is right now about 96% contained. Crews expect to get it to 100% at the end of this month or the start of the year. One of the hotshots from Little T, Matthew Jacquez, just came out with an album this month, under the name Unholy Smokes. This song is about constantly being on the road.
莉齐·约翰逊（Lizzie Johnson）在《旧金山纪事报》。她有一本关于天堂火灾的书要出版，你可以在线预订。溪火在燃烧了近四个月后，目前大约96%已得到控制。团队预计将在本月底或年初达到100%。Little T的热点队员之一，马修·雅克兹（Matthew Jacquez），这个月刚出了一张专辑，以Unholy Smokes的名字。这首歌是关于一直呆在路上的。
(SINGING) The great, big, galloping road grows between us now [INAUDIBLE]. We meet again some other day. Here I go again, wondering, my friend.
（歌唱）巨大的、飞奔的道路现在在我们之间生长[难以听清]。我们在某一天再见。我又出发了，我想知道，我的朋友。
Coming up, a scientist who's out snowboarding gets a call to come save the world. We move from hotshots to cold shots in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一位去滑雪的科学家接到一个电话去拯救世界。我们在一分钟内从热点到冷点，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Boulder v Hill-- stories of people trying to save the world by teaming up together and getting in there every day, doing the same things over and over, like Sisyphus pushing his rock up the slope again and again until the job gets done. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. In this act, we move from people who are saving us from something very large to people saving us from something tiny.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，巨石对阵山头——一群人试图通过团队合作来拯救世界，并且每天都在那里，一次又一次地做同样的事情，就像西西弗斯一次又一次地把他的石头推上坡，直到工作完成。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。在这一幕中，我们从拯救我们于某种非常巨大的事物的热点队员转移到拯救我们于某种微小事物的人身上。
Act Two, The Other Extinguishers. So, the people in this act have been working at a task, some of them for years, and this has been in the news in just the last few weeks. They have actually succeeded. It looks like they got their boulder up to the top of the hill. David Kestenbaum spoke with four scientists who have been working on a coronavirus vaccine, one of the ones that was just shown to be effective. David was a scientist in his early career. He worked at Fermilab. And from the coverage, he could not understand what exactly they had done in any detail. And he wanted to know that and who these people were and, especially, how does it feel to have helped make a thing that could save so many lives, fix the global economy, get life back to normal again for everybody. Here's David.
第二幕，另一个灭火者。所以，这一幕中的人们一直在从事一项任务，其中一些人已经坚持了几年，这在过去几周的新闻中也有报道。他们确实成功了。看起来他们把他们的巨石推到了山顶。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）采访了四位一直在研究冠状病毒疫苗的科学家，其中一种刚刚被证明是有效的。大卫在职业生涯早期是一名科学家。他在费米实验室工作。从报道中，他无法理解他们到底做了什么。他想知道这一点，他们是谁，尤其是，帮助制造一种能拯救如此多生命、修复全球经济、让一切恢复正常的东西感觉如何。这是大卫。
I'm going to tell you of the story of some of the people who made this one tiny thing. It's a key thing that's in at least five of the vaccines that are being tested. If you get the vaccine shot in the coming months, this thing will probably be injected into your body, and it could save your life. And the story of all this, you could start at all sorts of places. I'm going to begin here, in China.
我将告诉你一些制造这一个微小东西的人的故事。它是正在测试的至少五种疫苗中的关键事物。如果你在未来几个月接种疫苗，这个东西很可能会被注射到你的身体里，它可能会拯救你的生命。关于这一切的故事，你可以从各种地方开始。我将从这里开始，在中国。
I'm from a very small village around the east coast. It's Shandong province. And both my parents are farmers.
我来自东海岸的一个非常小的村庄。山东省。我的父母都是农民。
This is Nianshuang Wang. His way into science was playing outside and noticing bugs and locusts, scorpions, just got him curious about stuff.
这是王年双（Nianshuang Wang）。他进入科学的方式是在外面玩，注意到昆虫和蝗虫、蝎子，这让他对事物感到好奇。
Yeah, why we can think, why we need to eat food. Yeah, I'm curious about all those.
是的，为什么我们能思考，为什么我们需要吃食物。是的，我对所有这些都感到好奇。
It's funny. For me, it was when I was in 10th grade, I think. I learned about Newton's equation for gravity, and I learned that that explained both the orbits of the planets and also what happened when you dropped a ball. And I was like, I'm in. That's amazing. There's an equation that describes both of those perfectly. It was the rules behind the thing. It was the same thing.
很有趣。对我来说，是在10年级，我想。我了解了牛顿的重力方程，我了解到那既解释了行星的轨道，也解释了当你丢下一个球时发生了什么。我就想，我加入了。那太棒了。有一个描述了两者完美统一的方程。那是事物背后的规则。那是同一回事。
Yeah, those are really beautiful stuff. Yeah.
是的，那些真的是非常美丽的东西。是的。
When I first emailed Nianshuang, he was super excited to talk. He said no one had really interviewed him about all that he had done. Nianshuang got himself a scholarship to one of the top universities. And the thing he found himself gravitating toward is this field called structural biology, which I think favors a particular kind of person. You're basically trying to figure out what molecules look like, where all the atoms are, so you can tell how something works, or if it's a virus, how to fight it.
当我第一次给年双发邮件时，他非常兴奋地谈论。他说真的没有人采访过他关于他所做的一切。年双为自己赢得了顶尖大学的奖学金。他发现自己倾向于这个领域，称为结构生物学，我认为这偏向于特定类型的人。你基本上试图弄清楚分子长什么样，原子都在哪里，这样你就能知道某物是如何工作的，或者如果它是一种病毒，如何对抗它。
And the thing is, people work for years trying to figure out the structure of one tiny molecule. The traditional way of doing it is that you get a bunch of those molecules and try to get them to lay out in a neat, repeating pattern. Then you hit them with these powerful X-rays, which give you just this pattern of dots. Then you have to apply these mathematical algorithms. And sometimes, it's just not solvable. It really is like pushing a boulder to the top of a hill. It rolls down over and over.
问题是，人们工作多年试图弄清楚一个微小分子的结构。传统的方法是，你得到一堆分子，试图让它们以整齐、重复的模式排列。然后你用这些强大的X射线照射它们，这只给你这种点模式。然后你必须应用这些数学算法。有时，它就是无法解决。这真的就像把一块巨石推到山顶。它一次又一次地滚下来。
Nianshuang was good at it, though. For his thesis, he worked out the structure of part of a coronavirus. Not this coronavirus-- this was years ago. It was a coronavirus that was making the news back then, the MERS coronavirus, because it caused Middle East Respiratory Syndrome. After that, he needed a job, so he reached out to a guy who was also looking into MERS, Jason McClellan at Dartmouth.
不过年双很擅长。对于他的论文，他研究了冠状病毒一部分的结构。不是这个冠状病毒——那是几年前的事了。那是当时出现在新闻中的一种冠状病毒，中东呼吸综合征冠状病毒，因为它引起了中东呼吸综合征。之后，他需要一份工作，所以他联系了一个也一直在研究MERS的人，达特茅斯的贾森·麦克莱伦（Jason McLellan）。
How would your friends describe you?
你的朋友会怎么描述你？
Wow. I have no idea. Fun? Good to hang out with? Likes having a beer or two?
哇。我不知道。有趣？很好相处？喜欢喝一两杯啤酒？
Guy who's going to save the world?
一个要拯救世界的人？
I don't think that was on anyone's radar.
我不认为这在任何人的雷达上。
Nianshuang came over to the States to work with Jason and his team. This was 2014, six years before the pandemic. They wanted to make a vaccine for MERS. And one of the things they were trying to figure out back then that would end up being key for the vaccine we have today was, how to manufacture copies of the tiny spikes that were all over the surface of the MERS coronavirus.
年双来到美国与贾森和他的团队一起工作。那是2014年，大流行前六年。他们想为MERS制造一种疫苗。而他们当时试图弄清楚的其中一件事，即最终成为我们今天拥有的疫苗的关键，是：如何制造覆盖在MERS冠状病毒表面到处都是的微小尖刺的副本。
The spikes are why they're called the coronaviruses. The viruses have a corona, a wreath of these little spikes sticking out all over it. The spike is the part that sticks to your cells when it gets in your body, lets the virus break into your cells and start replicating. It's the scary part of the thing in a way. If they could make just the spikes without a deadly virus attached to them, maybe they could train your immune system to recognize the virus and fight it. But it turned out to be damn hard to make the spikes in the lab. Basically, you stick the genetic code for the spike into some cells.
尖刺是它们被称为冠状病毒的原因。病毒有一个皇冠，到处伸出的微小尖刺的花环。尖刺是当你进入体内时粘在你细胞上的部分，让病毒闯入你的细胞并开始复制。在某种程度上，它是那个东西的可怕部分。如果他们能只制造尖刺而不附带致命的病毒，也许他们可以训练你的免疫系统识别病毒并对抗它。但事实证明，在实验室里制造尖刺难得要命。基本上，你把尖刺的遗传密码粘到一些细胞里。
What are the cells?
细胞是什么？
We used two, either CHO cells, Chinese Hamster Ovary cells, or HEK293 cells.
我们用了两个，要么是CHO细胞，中国仓鼠卵巢细胞，或者HEK293细胞。
Which are what?
那是什么？
The Human Embryonic Kidney cells.
人类胚胎肾细胞。
I see.
我明白了。
I don't know why I wanted to know all this, except that this is the kind of knowledge that is going to save our asses. The problem was when they got the genetic code for the spikes into those cells, they did start spitting out spikes. But the cells weren't making a lot of them. And the spikes on their own were unstable. They kept changing into the wrong shape. Nianshuang spent a long time trying to stabilize them. Add something, tweak the genetic code. Try again, again. There's a tedium to it. Each try takes a while.
我不知道为什么我想知道所有这些，除了这是将要拯救我们屁股的知识类型。问题在于当他们得到尖刺的遗传密码进入那些细胞时，它们确实开始吐出尖刺。但细胞制造的并不多。而尖刺本身是不稳定的。它们不断变成错误的形状。年双花了很长时间试图稳定它们。添加一些东西，调整遗传密码。再试一次，再一次。这有种乏味。每次尝试都需要一段时间。
Around two or three weeks.
大约两到三周。
Two or three weeks. So you would start it, like, March 1st. By the third week in March, you'd be done with that test, and most of the time, it fails.
两到三周。所以你会在，比如3月1日开始。到3月的第三周，你完成那个测试，大多数时候，它失败了。
Yes.
是的。
And then you start again, and then you don't know for another three weeks if that new thing works.
然后你再次开始，然后你不知道再过三周那种新东西是否奏效。
Yes, yes. But we can do 10 at the same time as even more, 20.
是的，是的。但我们可以同时做10个，甚至更多，20个。
Oh, so you do 20 of them at the same time.
噢，所以你同时做20个。
Oh, yeah. We did a lot, actually.
噢，是的。我们实际上做了很多。
And every time you tried this, in your mind, are you like, oh, this time, it's going to work?
而且每次你尝试这个时，在你的脑海里，你是想，噢，这一次，它会奏效吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I was very confident sometimes. I said, it's going to work. If it won't work, I will drop this project. Then, usually I got disappointed.
我有时非常自信。我说，它会奏效。如果它不奏效，我就放弃这个项目。然后，通常我感到失望。
It's funny that you're so optimistic because most of the time, it fails, right? It just keeps failing and failing.
你如此乐观很有趣，因为大多数时候，它失败了，对吧？它一直在失败，一直在失败。
Yeah. that's kind of the life at the beginning.
是的。这有点像开始时的生活。
This kind of lab work, it's kind of like cooking, but for the fussiest restaurant ever. Lots of little, precise steps. You mix the stuff up in a flask, set it on this little platform which gently swirls the stuff in it, keep the whole thing at 37 degrees Celsius, leave it overnight. So you're constantly having to be at the lab at a certain time to do the next step. His wife told him, "You always say it'll be five minutes, but it's hours."
这种实验室工作，有点像烹饪，但对于有史以来最挑剔的餐厅。许多微小的、精确的步骤。你把东西在烧瓶里混合，放在这个不断轻轻旋转东西的小平台上，把整个东西保持在37摄氏度，过夜。所以你必须不断地在某个时间出现在实验室做下一步。他的妻子告诉他，“你总是说只需要五分钟，但却是几个小时。”
They tried so many different things, scouring the scientific literature for different ideas, modifying them. The thing that finally worked was changing the genetic code for the spike so it would swap in two prolene amino acids. They helped hold the spike in its spike form, kept it from changing shape. Also, the cells were spitting out way more spikes-- 50 times more.
他们尝试了许多不同的东西，在科学文献中搜寻不同的想法，修改它们。最终奏效的是改变尖刺的遗传密码，这样它会交换两个普罗琳氨基酸。它们帮助保持尖刺在其尖刺形式，防止它改变形状。而且，细胞吐出了更多的尖刺——多出50倍。
The day it worked was really exciting because Nianshuang, who'd been doing all of this work, it's a lot of trial and error. You're basically just failing until it works. And finally, he got one. We're like, wow, that looks fantastic. We knew we had something then.
奏效的那一天真的很令人兴奋，因为年双，他一直在做所有这些工作，这有很多试错。你基本上只是在失败直到它奏效。最后，他得到了一个。我们想，哇，看起来太棒了。那时我们就知道我们得到了什么。
When they vaccinated mice, gave them a shot containing these MERS coronavirus spikes, the mice's little immune systems developed antibodies-- lots of them. It looked really promising, like you might be able to make a really good vaccine against the MERS coronavirus. This was basically the road map for the vaccine we were all going to need when the pandemic started. But the major scientific journals were not interested in publishing it.
当他们给老鼠接种疫苗，给它们注射含有这些MERS冠状病毒尖刺的针时，老鼠微小的免疫系统产生了抗体——很多很多。看起来非常有希望，就像你可以制造一种对抗MERS冠状病毒的非常好的疫苗一样。这基本上是我们所有人开始流行时需要的疫苗的路线图。但主要的科学期刊对发表它不感兴趣。
We totally tried six different journals, and it was rejected five times.
我们总共尝试了六种不同的期刊，它被拒绝了五次。
Wow, that's kind of amazing looking back now.
哇，现在回顾起来有点令人震惊。
Yeah, if we look back, yeah. Yeah, I was getting sad after three rejections, four rejections, five rejections. Yeah.
是的，如果我们回顾，是的。是的，经过三次拒绝、四次拒绝、五次拒绝后，我变得很难过。是的。
He told me he fell into a real depression. No one seemed to see the value of their work. He saw a therapist, who pointed out all he had accomplished and suggested that he might feel proud instead of sad. It didn't really help. This was 2017. The pandemic was three years away. The fact that they had trouble getting it published, to me, it doesn't mean the scientific journal editors are idiots. Back then, most people thought the next pandemic was going to be some new form of influenza, not a coronavirus, which, of course, is the argument for funding lots of basic research. Sometimes you don't know what thing is going to be important.
他告诉我他陷入了真正的抑郁。没有人似乎看到他们工作的价值。他看了一位治疗师，对方指出了他所取得的所有成就，并建议他可能会感到自豪而不是难过。那并没有真正帮助。那是2017年。大流行还有三年。他们难以发表这个事实，对我来说，并不意味着科学期刊编辑是白痴。那时，大多数人认为下一次大流行将是某种新型流感，而不是冠状病毒，这当然是资助大量基础研究的论据。有时你不知道什么东西会变得重要。
When the current pandemic began, Jason McLellan had moved his lab from Dartmouth to the University of Texas at Austin. Nianshuang had gone with him. Jason told me one day in January, January 6th, he was in Utah snowboarding, and he got a call from the deputy director of the Vaccine Research Center at the National Institutes of Health, Barney Graham. Graham had been working with him on all the MERS coronavirus stuff, and he was calling about some pneumonia-like illness in Wuhan, China. The local health authority was reporting 41 cases.
当当前大流行开始时，贾森·麦克莱伦已将他的实验室从达特茅斯搬到了德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校。年双跟着他去了。贾森告诉我有一天在1月，1月6日，他在犹他滑雪，他接到了美国国立卫生研究院疫苗研究中心副主任巴尼·格雷厄姆（Barney Graham）的电话。格雷厄姆一直与他一起研究所有这些MERS冠状病毒的东西，他正在打电话谈论中国武汉的一种类似肺炎的疾病。当地卫生部门报告了41例病例。
He let me know he was talking with the US CDC, and they wanted to quickly make a vaccine candidate. And it looked like it was a beta coronavirus. And he wanted to know, are we game? Are we going to-- can we help out try to rapidly determine the structure of the spike and get the vaccine made? And--
他让我知道他正在与美国CDC谈论，他们想迅速制造一种候选疫苗。看起来它是一种β冠状病毒。他想知道，我们有兴趣吗？我们能，我们能帮忙尝试迅速确定尖刺的结构并制造出疫苗吗？而且——
You said, I'm busy, I'm snowboarding.
你说，我很忙，我在滑雪。
Yeah, I was actually-- I was getting some boots heat molded, so I had 10 minutes to talk to him while they were heat molding to my feet. But I immediately WhatsApped my grad student, Daniel Rapp, and told him, we're going to race. We got to move quickly on this. Let's get prepared.
是的，实际上——我正在让靴子进行热塑，所以我只有10分钟和他谈话，当它们在给我的脚进行热塑时。但我立即给我的研究生丹尼尔·拉普（Daniel Rapp）发了WhatsApp，告诉他，我们要比赛了。我们必须迅速行动。让我们准备好。
It's worth pointing out, they were running full steam at this in January. This is before Wuhan went into lockdown, before that giant hospital got built. The whole thing was barely in the news. And life here, it was totally normal. So they were all going to the office to work frantically on this thing, while, all around them, people are going to restaurants and church. Kids are in school.
值得指出的是，他们在1月就在全力以赴。这在武汉封锁之前，在那座巨大的医院建成之前。整件事几乎没有上新闻。而这里的生活，完全正常。所以他们都在去办公室疯狂地研究这个东西，而周围的人们都在去餐厅和教堂。孩子们在上学。
The thing they were going to try to help make is called an mRNA vaccine. Instead of giving people shots filled with coronavirus spikes, you inject people with the genetic code for making the spikes. The code is wrapped in this little package. And once it gets injected into your body, it goes into your cells. And then your cells start making the spikes-- loads of them, which, on their own, are harmless. But your immune system sees these foreign things and learns to fight it, which should hopefully protect you if the real virus comes along.
他们试图帮助制造的东西被称为mRNA疫苗。不是给人们注射装满冠状病毒尖刺的针，你给人们注射制造尖刺的遗传密码。代码被包裹在这个小包装里。一旦它被注射到你的身体里，它就进入你的细胞。然后你的细胞开始制造尖刺——大量的尖刺，它们本身是无害的。但你的免疫系统看到了这些外来事物并学习去对抗它，如果真正的病毒到来，这应该有望保护你。
This is the genius of vaccines. We're not that good at making drugs against viruses. But you know what's really good at fighting them? Our immune system. If you can just show it the right piece of the virus, it often figures out how to fight it off. It's like the answer we all have inside us.
这就是疫苗的天才之处。我们不擅长制造对抗病毒的药物。但你知道什么擅长对抗它们吗？我们的免疫系统。如果你能只给它展示病毒正确的部分，它通常会弄清楚如何击退它。就像我们每个人内部都有的答案一样。
The big thing they had to work out for the vaccine was what part of the genetic sequence for the coronavirus were they going to stick in the vaccine to make the spikes. And how were they going to alter that code so that when the spike was created, it would be stable and not twist around? Five days after Jason got that phone call, Chinese researchers posted the genetic code for the new coronavirus online so teams around the world could look at it. Jason and the others started going through it right away.
他们必须为疫苗解决的大事是他们要往疫苗里粘冠状病毒遗传序列的哪一部分来制造尖刺。而且他们打算如何改变那个密码，以便在创造出尖刺时，它是稳定的且不会扭曲？贾森接到那个电话五天后，中国研究人员在网上发布了新冠状病毒的遗传密码，以便世界各地的团队可以查看它。贾森和其他人立即开始查看它。
So how long did it take? So you get the sequence, and how long until you're like, this is the thing we want in the vaccine?
那么花了多长时间？你得到序列，然后多久你才想，这是我们想要在疫苗里的东西？
Oh, an hour maybe.
噢，大概一个小时。
Really?
真的吗？
It was probably within 10 minutes. I mean, as soon as you did the sequence alignment, you just put them in. Yeah.
可能在10分钟内。我的意思是，一旦你做了序列比对，你就直接把它们放进去。是的。
That's because the spike on this coronavirus that would cause the pandemic, it was very, very similar to the one on the MERS coronavirus, the one they had been studying.
这是因为这种导致大流行的冠状病毒上的尖刺，它与MERS冠状病毒上的那个非常、非常相似，那个他们一直在研究的。
It's often noted that these vaccines came together really quickly.
人们常说这些疫苗结合得非常快。
But it seems like the reason they came together really quickly is because of all this work that went on for years before.
但看起来它们结合得非常快的原因是因为在过去几年里发生的所有这些工作。
Yeah, I think that's right. And yeah, it definitely is. Just--
是的，我认为那是对的。而且是的，绝对是。只是——
It's not like it just happened in 30 days. It happened in 10 years.
这不像它只是在30天内发生的。它是在10年内发生的。
Yeah, I saw a nice graphic online showing that if SARS-COV-2 had emerged 10 years ago, we'd be nowhere this far along to having a vaccine.
是的，我在网上看到一张不错的图表，显示如果SARS-COV-2在10年前出现，我们在拥有疫苗方面将远远落后。
They sent the genetic sequence off to a company that they've been communicating with for a while called Moderna. Moderna, like a bunch of other scientists and other companies, have been working for years on how to even make an mRNA vaccine, which is a whole other story. Anyway, a few weeks later, they had one ready for testing.
他们把遗传序列发送给了一家他们交流了一段时间的公司，名叫Moderna。Moderna，像一堆其他科学家和其他公司一样，多年来一直在研究如何甚至制造mRNA疫苗，这是另一个故事。无论如何，几周后，他们有了一个可以测试的。
I mean, this is the first vaccine to potentially be tested in humans for what was then a burgeoning pandemic.
我的意思是，这是第一个潜在地在人类中测试的疫苗，用于当时正在萌芽的大流行。
This is Kizzmekia Corbett, a viral immunologist at the NIH, who'd been working with Jason and Nianshuang and everyone else. She was there when the package arrived from Moderna. And just a note about Kizzmekia, she told me that she was one of those kids who won all the science fairs, couldn't leave a math problem unsolved. And also, when the Nobel prizes were announced, she would write the speeches she would imagine they would deliver and read them out loud, pretending to deliver them in a very dramatic way with tears, as if they were the Oscars or something. Anyway, she was the one who went to get the box of the first vaccines when they arrived.
这是基兹梅基亚·科比特（Kizzmekia Corbett），NIH的病毒免疫学家，一直在与贾森、年双和所有人一起工作。她在Moderna的包裹到达时也在那里。关于基兹梅基亚的一点笔记，她告诉我她是那种赢得所有科学博览会的孩子之一，不能留下一个数学问题未解决。而且，当诺贝尔奖宣布时，她会写下她想象他们会发表的演讲，并大声朗读，假装以一种非常戏剧性的方式发表它们，伴着泪水，就像它们是奥斯卡奖一样。无论如何，她是第一个在疫苗到达时去取盒子的人。
It came, and I-- this is the first time anything came from Moderna where I had to show my ID. And I remember the loading dock people couldn't even bring the box up to me. I had to meet the driver downstairs. I don't even think it came on a plane. I actually think that they had it driven from Boston to Bethesda.
它来了，而且我——这是Moderna发出的第一样我必须出示证件的东西。我记得装卸码头的人甚至不能把盒子给我。我必须下楼去见司机。我甚至不认为它是在飞机上来的。我实际上认为他们是把它从波士顿开车运到贝塞斯达的。
When you got that box, what did you think?
当你拿到那个盒子时，你怎么想？
I remember asking the guy at the loading dock to take a picture. And he was like, I can't. [LAUGHS] Can you take a pic I was like, can you take a picture of me with this box? And he's like, oh, no, I can't do that.
我记得要求装卸码头的那个人拍张照。他说，我不能。[笑]你可以拍张照吗？我当时想，你能拍一张我和这个盒子的照片吗？他说，噢，不，我不能那样做。
Because he was too busy?
因为他太忙了？
No, I mean, that's because it's not his job. [LAUGHS] And I'm just this nerdy scientist about to vaccinate some 250 mice with a vaccine. I mean, and neither of us really understood the gravity.
不，我的意思是，这是因为那不是他的工作。[笑]而我只是一个即将用疫苗给大约250只老鼠接种的极客科学家。我的意思是，而且我们俩都没有真正理解它的严重性。
This was in February. Kizzmekia remembers at some point going to see her family, sitting down on her mom's bed, and kind of briefing everyone. "I think things might really change soon. I think the virus is about to be a big problem." I talked to all the researchers about what it was like in this period, making and testing a vaccine they hoped would work, but not knowing. Meanwhile, more and more of the world was shutting down, more people getting sick and dying. Kizzmekia told me she used to look at the daily numbers for the world and then had to stop. It wasn't healthy.
这是在2月。基兹梅基亚记得在某个时候去看望她的家人，坐在她妈妈的床上，并向每个人做简报。“我认为事情很快就会真正改变。我认为病毒即将成为一个大问题。”我与所有研究人员谈论了在那期间是什么感觉，制造和测试一种他们希望有效的疫苗，但却不知道。与此同时，世界上越来越多的人在关闭，更多的人在生病和死亡。基兹梅基亚告诉我她过去看世界每天的数字，然后不得不停止。那不健康。
Barney Graham is Kizzmekia's boss. He is the deputy director of the Vaccine Research Center at the NIH and the guy who called Jason while he was snowboarding. He'd worked with them on all of this stuff, the most senior member of the group. It weighed on him, though he didn't always recognize it. He says he's not always in touch with his feelings. We talked in the evening, and he was at home where he had been for months. Sitting in front of a bookcase, a little bust of Benjamin Franklin on it, he seemed tired. Making the vaccine took so many steps, so many decisions.
巴尼·格雷厄姆是基兹梅基亚的老板。他是NIH疫苗研究中心的副主任，也就是在贾森滑雪时给他打电话的那个人。他与他们一起研究所有这些东西，是小组中资历最深的成员。这对他来说很沉重，尽管他并不总是意识到。他说他并不总是与他的感情保持联系。我们在晚上谈话，他在家里，已经待了几个月了。坐在书架前，上面有一个本杰明·富兰克林的半身像，他看起来很累。制造疫苗采取了这么多步骤，这么多决定。
Most of the time, you just grind through the day and try to make the best decisions you can, and keep everybody moving. And there's also a sequence. Things have to happen in a certain order, or you get blocked. And so, just keeping things moving takes up most of my attention most of the time. Maybe my wife could say something.
大多数时候，你只是熬过一天，并尝试做出你能做出的最好决定，并让每个人保持行动。而且还有一个顺序。事情必须以某种顺序发生，否则你会被阻塞。所以，仅仅保持事情进展就占据了我大部分时间的大部分注意力。也许我妻子能说点什么。
And then, his wife, who was in the room while we were talking-- her name is Cynthia-- jumped in.
然后，他的妻子，在我们谈话时在房间里——她的名字是辛西娅——插话了。
Well, I--
嗯，我——
She's a psychiatrist and, at a couple of points, had been chiming in a very sweet way to sort of explain her husband's calm exterior. She said, you're forgetting the story, which she started to tell.
她是一位精神科医生，在几个时候以非常甜美的方式插话，试图解释她丈夫冷静的外表。她说，你忘了那个故事，她开始讲述。
He came out of his office, and he was clearly distracted and upset. And of course, if you want to know what's going on with Barney, you have to ask him. And you have to not let him off the hook until he tells you. And so, I continue to just probe. And he said, what if I selected the wrong sequence?
他从办公室出来，明显心烦意乱。当然，如果你想知道巴尼发生了什么，你必须问他。而且你不能让他逃脱，直到他告诉你。所以，我继续只是探询。他说，如果我选择了错误的序列怎么办？
'Cause we had selected a sequence--
因为我们选择了一个序列——
Right.
对。
--initially, but the question was--
——最初，但问题是——
Was it the right one?
是正确的那个吗？
Usually, we spend months or even years experimenting to decide this is the best one to use.
通常，我们花几个月甚至几年时间实验来决定这是最好的一个使用。
He was worried about the time that would be wasted in the development of the vaccine itself and how many people would die, how many children would be left without parents, how many old people would not get to see their grandchildren grow up. I mean, he was just thinking about all of the terrible consequences if this had been the wrong choice.
他担心疫苗本身开发中将浪费的时间，以及有多少人会死亡，多少孩子会失去父母，多少老人将无法看到孙辈长大。我的意思是，他只是在思考如果这是错误的决定，所有的可怕后果。
It's just, like I said, I tend to be a little obsessive. And you just can't get certain ideas or thought patterns out of your head until you find the resolution.
就像我说的那样，我倾向于有点强迫症。你只是不能把某些想法或思维模式从你的脑海里赶走，直到你找到决议。
Clinical trials began on March 16, which is pretty incredible. This is right around the time when businesses were just deciding it would be safer to work from home. Shots were eventually given to tens of thousands of people. And then the wait began to see if it worked.
临床试验于3月16日开始，这相当令人难以置信。这大约是企业刚刚决定居家办公更安全的时候。针最终被注射给了成千上万的人。然后等待开始，看它是否有效。
Meanwhile, the coronavirus kept spreading in the US, or, as the president called it, the "kung-flu" and the "China virus." Here's Nianshuang.
与此同时，冠状病毒在美国持续蔓延，或者，如总统称之为的“功夫流感”和“中国病毒”。这是年双。
I'm from China. I do have some feeling that yeah, the president should not say that to my home country. I'm pretty angry by that. I think that it makes no sense.
我来自中国。我确实有一些感觉，是的，总统不应该那样说我的祖国。我对那感到非常愤怒。我认为那根本没意义。
It was offensive, but it also just struck him as dumb. There were so many things the president needed to be doing to tame the pandemic. Why was he wasting his time with this? And then-- maybe you remember this-- there was a story in the news back then about how the FBI was looking into whether Chinese spies working through the consulate in Houston had tried to steal vaccine research. The FBI was going to be questioning people at the University of Texas. One story included Nianshuang's name as someone who worked there from China. Friends told him to get a lawyer. He says he and his wife looked into whether they could leave the country if they needed to. In the end, no one came to question him, but it was unnerving.
这很有冒犯性，但它也只是让他觉得愚蠢。总统需要做的事情来驯服大流行太多了。他为什么要浪费时间在这个上？然后——也许你还记得这个——新闻里有一个故事，关于FBI如何调查是否中国间谍通过休斯顿领事馆试图窃取疫苗研究。FBI将要在德克萨斯大学审问人。一个故事包括年双的名字作为从中国在那工作的人。朋友告诉他找个律师。他说他和他的妻子调查了如果需要他们是否能离开这个国家。最后，没人来审问他，但那令人不安。
The moment when all these researchers learned that their vaccine was going to work was a few weeks ago when Pfizer announced that its vaccine was more than 90% effective. Pfizer had started its phase three clinical trials on the same day as them, but Pfizer got its results first. Pfizer had used in its vaccine the thing this team had come up with, the coronavirus spike stabilized the way they had figured out. Pfizer had licensed it from them. So if the Pfizer vaccine worked, they figured theirs would, too. Barney Graham got a call before the results went public.
所有这些研究人员得知他们的疫苗将有效的时刻是几周前，当辉瑞宣布其疫苗有效性超过90%时。辉瑞在同一天开始了其三期临床试验，但辉瑞先得到了结果。辉瑞在其疫苗中使用了这个团队想出的东西，即他们弄清楚的稳定方式的冠状病毒尖刺。辉瑞从他们那里获得了许可。所以如果辉瑞疫苗有效，他们认为他们的也会。巴尼·格雷厄姆在结果公布前接到了电话。
I've been right here in my office for 10 months. So I was in my office. And it was in the evening, late evening. And apparently, their data and safety monitoring board had met earlier in the day. And they were going to put out a press release the next day on Monday. And I got off the phone. I went over and sheepishly told my wife and my son, who was visiting at the time, that it looks like it's going to work.
我已经在我的办公室里待了10个月。所以我在我的办公室里。那是在晚上，深夜。显然，他们的数据和安全监测委员会在当天早些时候开会了。他们将在周一的第二天发布新闻稿。我挂了电话。我走过去，胆怯地告诉我的妻子和当时正在探望的儿子，看起来它要奏效了。
And that just kind of released a lot of emotion I think that I've been holding back for the last 10 months. And so, I retreated back into my office and just kind of let all that out for a few minutes. And they all came in and consoled me. But that moment kind of caught me by surprise that there was so much in there to come out.
而那释放了许多我过去10个月一直压抑的情绪。所以我退回到我的办公室，让所有那些在几分钟内释放出来。他们都进来了，安慰我。但那个时刻有点让我吃惊，里面有这么多东西要出来。
The whole family was in tears.
全家人都在流泪。
It's just a relief to know that you've gotten to that point. Because in vaccine development, there is 1,000 choices to make, 1,000 decisions, and 1,000 ways to fail. And most of these kind of development projects don't turn out. And to get through all the way to get an answer that said it worked and even worked better than you expected, that was quite a moment.
知道你已经到了那个点是一种解脱。因为在疫苗开发中，有1000个选择要做，1000个决定，1000种失败的方法。而大多数这种开发项目都没有成功。一直走到得到一个说它有效的答案，甚至比你预期的效果更好，那真是一个时刻。
Yeah, I wasn't expecting to be emotional at all. I for sure wasn't expecting to be crying happy tears for Pfizer, that's for sure. [LAUGHS]
是的，我根本没想到会情绪化。我肯定没想到会为辉瑞流下幸福的泪水，那是肯定的。[笑]
What kind of a cry was it? There are lots of different kinds of cries.
那是什么样的哭泣？有很多不同类型的哭泣。
OK, so if my family or if my siblings or my friends are listening to this, first of all, they're like, OK, yeah, right, you haven't cried this entire year. You cry all the time. So I'm a huge cry baby, and my cries are ugly. It was the cry you might expect to have if you won the lottery.
好的，所以如果我的家人或者我的兄弟姐妹或者我的朋友在听这个，首先，他们会想，好的，是的，没错，你今年从来没哭过。你一直在哭。所以我是一个巨大的爱哭鬼，而我的哭很丑。它是那种如果你赢了彩票可能会有的哭泣。
I don't even know if my family even today understands what just happened with me over the last year. If I were to call them about 90% efficacy results, they'd be like, OK, what is that? I actually still haven't communicated with my family about the efficacy results at all. I talk to them all the time. I just talked to my dad this morning about fixing a dishwasher in my rental property, so I talk to them all the time. But I don't know.
我甚至不知道我的家人今天是否理解过去一年我身上发生了什么。如果我要打电话给他们关于90%功效的结果，他们会说，好的，那是什么？我实际上仍然根本没有与我的家人交流关于功效结果的事。我一直在与他们谈话。我今天早上才刚刚和爸爸谈过修复我出租房里的洗碗机，所以我一直在与他们谈话。但我不知道。
Yeah, it feels, oh, God, it's actually working now. So it's really going to save a lot of people. So I think I'm proud of it. And it's great.
是的，感觉，噢，上帝，它现在真的在奏效。所以它真的要拯救很多人。所以我认为我为此感到自豪。而且它太棒了。
That little thing you made might fix the global economy. It could save millions of lives. It could help everything get back to normal, that little thing.
你制造的那个微小东西可能修复全球经济。它可能拯救数百万生命。它可能帮助一切恢复正常，那个微小东西。
Yeah, that's what I hope. Yeah.
是的，那就是我希望的。是的。
What do your parents say?
你的父母怎么说？
My parents, actually, they don't know what I was doing. They just know, oh, you developed a vaccine. That's great. [LAUGHS] That's their thinking. They don't know how much contribution I did. Yeah, actually, they-- yeah, my mom got stroke several years ago. She may never know what I'm doing now, so.
我的父母，实际上，他们不知道我在做什么。他们只知道，噢，你开发了一种疫苗。那太棒了。[笑]那是他们的想法。他们不知道我贡献了多少。是的，实际上，他们——是的，我妈妈几年前中风了。她可能永远不知道我现在在做什么，所以。
I'm sorry about your mom.
为你妈妈感到抱歉。
Yeah, I'm a little sad about that. But she had encouraged a lot in the past, yeah. I will always remember those things, yeah.
是的，我为此有点难过。但她在过去鼓励了很多，是的。我永远会记得那些事，是的。
It can be hard, I think, when you're in deep with something complicated to explain that thing to someone on the outside, particularly with science. There's this version that often makes it out into the world of a single person having a clear, dramatic breakthrough-- Jonas Salk with the polio vaccine. The Nobel Prize is always given to one or a few people. But a lot of science isn't like that. I think most of it isn't.
当你深入复杂的事情时，向局外人解释那件事可能会很困难，特别是科学。有一个版本通常会进入世界，即单个人有一个清晰、戏剧性的突破——乔纳斯·索尔克（Jonas Salk）和脊髓灰质炎疫苗。诺贝尔奖总是颁给一个人或几个人。但很多科学并不是那样的。我想大多数都不是。
When I asked Jason McClellan, the other scientist in this story, about his contribution to this, he started listing names, all the people whose work went before or whose ideas they adapted. Kizzmekia, when she gives talks, her last slides are just lists of names. It's never just one person pushing the rock up a hill.
当我问贾森·麦克莱伦，这个故事里的另一位科学家，关于他对这个的贡献时，他开始列出名字，所有在他之前工作或者他们的想法被采纳的人。基兹梅基亚，当她演讲时，她的最后几张幻灯片只是名字列表。这从来不仅仅是一个人把石头推上山。
David Kestenbaum is senior editor of our show. The NIH Moderna vaccine protected 94% of the people who got it in clinical trial. It was just this week approved for emergency use. The government has arranged to purchase 200 million doses.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的高级编辑。NIH Moderna疫苗在临床试验中保护了94%的人。它就在本周被批准用于紧急使用。政府已经安排购买2亿剂。
[MUSIC - "ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF THE OTHER" BY EMILIE AUTUMN]
[音乐 - EMILIE AUTUMN的“ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF THE OTHER”]
Well, our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put our show together today include Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Noor Gill, Hilary Elkins, Damien Graves, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry.
嗯，我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）制作。今天把我们节目组合在一起的人包括达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、希拉里·埃尔金斯（Hilary Elkins）、达米恩·格雷夫斯（Damien Graves）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑，埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks today to Derek Lowe, Daniel Patterson, Pedro Marron, Adan Luna, Chuck Ramirez, Ryan Mendoza, Jenn Rosas, JB Bunton, Thea Phimmasy, Miguel Diaz, Gilbert Mendoza, Francisco Murillo, Forrest Lamp, John Clearwater, and Christina Crawford. Our website where we set up a special page to note our show's 25th year on the air with a list of favorite shows from over the years and have written little blurbs explaining why each of the shows made the list, plus award-winning shows and spinoff shows, that's thisamericanlife.org/25years. Again, thisamericanlife.org/25years.
今天特别感谢德里克·洛（Derek Lowe）、丹尼尔·帕特森（Daniel Patterson）、佩德罗·马伦（Pedro Marron）、阿丹·卢纳（Adan Luna）、查克·拉米雷斯（Chuck Ramirez）、瑞安·门多萨（Ryan Mendoza）、詹·罗萨斯（Jenn Rosas）、JB·邦顿（JB Bunton）、西娅·菲马西（Thea Phimmasy）、米格尔·迪亚兹（Miguel Diaz）、吉尔伯特·门多萨（Gilbert Mendoza）、弗朗西斯科·穆里略（Francisco Murillo）、福雷斯特·兰普（Forrest Lamp）、约翰·克利尔沃特（John Clearwater）和克里斯蒂娜·克劳福德（Christina Crawford）。我们的网站，我们在那里设立了一个特殊页面来记录我们节目播出25周年，列出了多年来最受欢迎的节目，并写了一些小短文解释为什么每个节目都在名单上，加上获奖节目和衍生节目，那是thisamericanlife.org/25years。再一次，thisamericanlife.org/25years。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, we were arguing over the greatest daytime TV talk shows of all time. I personally have always been a fan of Oprah. Torey disagreed.
《This American Life》由公共广播交换平台PRX交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，我们一直在争论有史以来最伟大的日间电视谈话节目。我个人一直是奥普拉（Oprah）的粉丝。托雷不同意。
The View is great, you know?
《The View》很棒，你知道吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF THE OTHER" BY EMILIE AUTUMN]
[音乐 - EMILIE AUTUMN的“ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF THE OTHER”]